[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de la grande interview avec cette
semaine nicolas rousselet le président
de l'ag 7
bonjour président croit merci à vous
diriger une des plus vieilles et sans
doute une des plus importantes
compagnies de taxis en france
ça fait combien de taxi c'est à 7 à 9
minutes ou 9000 taxi à paris et capitale
quatre mille affiliés en province alors
beaucoup de choses à nous apprendre
d'abord comment vous subissez que
vraiment vous assumer cette conjoncture
car avait été compliquée avec la
pandémie puisqu'elle a tout bloqué avec
le confinement et puis les mutations
structurelles parce que c'est un des
secteurs fortement concurrencé je pense
notamment à tous les vtc je pense
notamment à tous les indépendants qui
peuvent s'improviser où s'installer
comme comme comme chauffeur aujourd'hui
un mot sur l'actualité l'activité a
repris zdar actuellement dans paris ou
pas où l activité on est revenu à 90% de
la demande de taxis g7 donc au travers
de notre plate forme tout en ayant une
situation assez contrastée puisque dans
les gares et les aéroports on est entre
30 et 50 % d'activité donc les
chauffeurs de taxi affiliés à notre
plateforme ont à peu près le même nombre
de courses par jour il avait en 2019
mais par contre dans l'activité rue avec
l'augmentation du télétravail avec la
vie sociale qui reprend tout doucement
et surtout avec la l'absence de
touristes étrangers
les chauffeurs sont un peu à la peine
dans la rue donc donc voyez une
situation plutôt contrasté 90% sur la
plate forme de retour à une activité
type 2019 et dans la rue par contre les
courses aéroports l'activité touristique
et est vraiment en mer ben ça c'est pas
réveiller encore non là c'est vraiment
ambert il faut dire que on continue à
aider les taxis 1 parce que ça fait
partie de l'outil touristique pour la
reprise ils vont bien revenir aux amis
touristes étrangers donc là l' activité
contrastée mais la plateforme
on est revenu à 90 % de l'activité de
les chauffeurs eux mêmes 80 % ont repris
leurs activités avec notre plateforme
donc tout tout tout le mouvement nous
rend très optimiste où on a une
croissance de l'activité du nombre de
chauffeurs affiliés
ça se présente plutôt pas mal alors la
quasi-totalité sondés sont des
chauffeurs indépendants ils sont
artisans de ce statut pour la plupart
ils ont quand même été durement
affectées directement est-ce qu'ils ont
été aidés alors cette période
c'est vrai que on a le premier
confinement on a eu une baisse très
forte d'activité les chauffeurs se sont
néanmoins mobilisées 330000 soignants
ont été transportés en 2020 les
dispositifs dead ont été mis en place
par l'état
mais très vite nous on a été solidaires
de nos chauffeurs
on est dans la même équipe donc on a mis
par exemple des remises sur le loyer
qu'ils nous payent chaque chaque mois
sur la plateforme
on a mis des facilités pour qu'il puisse
suspendre leurs activités de la
plateforme le temps de passer cette
crise on s'est occupé d'eux on a on a
investi pas loin de 10 millions il ya eu
des aides gouvernementales alors
derrière bénéficier gouvernementale
effectivement derrière l'état a mis en
place un dispositif et et bravo pour
garder cet outil touristique en fait et
l'état a mis en place des compensations
relatives aux baisses de chiffre
d'affaires par rapport à l'année
précédente
et grâce à ça on passe la crise tentant
bien que faire se peut mais on passe la
crise voilà alors dans l'actualité très
récente d'un point d'interrogation sur
l'état sanitaire à la fois des taxis et
des chauffeurs est ce qu'ils sont
vaccinés alors les chauffeurs ont eu des
vaccinations prioritaire ils se sont ils
se sont vraiment prioritaire a
maintenant et qui sont priorisées la
crise ils vont ils y vont se lever très
tôt et on a mis en place avec eux un
protocole sanitaire renforcée pour que
le taxi soit le mode de transport à 4 ou
le plus sûr en ville on a dès avril 2020
mis en place avec le bureau veritas
ces mesures de précaution gel
hydroalcoolique aération l'habitacle des
infections des poignées de porte et les
chauffeurs de taxi ils ont joué le jeu
ils ont joué le jeu
60% d'entre eux ont mis par exemple une
paroisse de séparation entre le passager
et protection des deux protections du
chauffeur protection du client donc
aujourd'hui cc on a vu pendant cette
crise sanitaire le taxi c'est vraiment
un des modes de transport qui protège
beaucoup plus qu'un transport collectif
complexe que je peux savoir moi ans je
mens
dans un taxi que le chauffeur et
vacciner ou pas
aujourd'hui vous le secret médical fait
que chaque s'éteint c'est une non pas
par ya pas de qr codes à la disposition
du du du client ou pas je vois taxi le
masque est obligatoire pour le client et
pour le chauffeur 60% des taxis dans une
paroisse de séparation il ya vraiment
des conditions sanitaires optimales et
on l'a vu puisque en fait les la
fréquentation des transports publics
s'est effondré pendant cette crise
sanitaire
alors alors même que l'activité de la
plateforme g7 est restée à des niveaux
tout à fait honorable pour que nos
chauffeurs de taxi puissent continuer à
travailler à faire leur mission un peu
de service public laurie joue au poker
précisément cette question parce que le
gouvernement a pris la décision de
rendre prioritaire l'accès de catégories
de personnels prioritaires à la
vaccination
c'est normal 20 personnes transportées
par jour c'est important que les
chauffeurs de taxis soient protégés qui
protège ce qui se concocte un jeu même
et qui protègent leurs clients vous avez
fait une action vous même vis-à-vis des
chauffeurs une incitation à la la
vaccination à nouveau en descente ou en
bas en parrainant un certain nombre de
100 onces et on s'est beaucoup battu on
a une série à l'autorité régionale de
santé pour inscrire en priorité les
chauffeurs de taxi oui c'est et on a
mené des attaques système hôte de
transport partagé 20 personnes 20
personnes transportées par jour dont
beaucoup de contacts 330000 soyons donc
il faut protéger les chauffeurs de taxi
comme il faut protéger les clients non
mais tu peux l'écrire parce qu'il y
avait quand même une réticence dans la
population française
il y en a encore une espèce de méfiance
à l'égard du à l'égard du du vaccin qui
peut être un frein finalement là à la
vaccination global ci et notamment au
niveau du d'immunité collectif qu'on
espère en septembre/octobre m'échauffant
taxi se sont vraiment mobilisés là
dessus ils étaient ravis d'apprendre
on s'est battus à leurs côtés pour avoir
cette vaccination prioritaire protection
sont très concernés encore une fois il
était en quasi première ligne le
transport des soignants et bravo à eux
c'est courageux il n'y avait pas de
séparation à l'époque au tout début de
la pandémie
ils sortaient ils remplissaient une
mission de quasi le service public
alors j'ai regardé en regardant
l'histoire un peu de ce métier c'est un
très vieux métiers il est né avec
l'automobile g7 existe depuis qu'en 1905
a été créée en 1905
l'histoire de la jet set c'est une série
de transformations la g7 a été créée en
1905 par des ingénieurs qui ont parié
sur le remplacement de la voiture à
cheval mais personne n'y croyait à louis
renault lui-même avait parié là dessus
absolument je voulais vendre ses
voitures mais pourquoi abandonner les
voitures à cheval ça va beaucoup plus
vite qu'une voiture à moteur thermique
en 1905 donc sur vous en avais des
écolos à l'époque qui avait déjà sorti
des étudiants 10 ans si on continue avec
la voiture à cheval on sera absolument
asphyxiée par le crottin de cheval
raps absolument donc la première
première rupture qui a donné la création
à la g7 en 1905
ouais puis derrière c'est une c'est une
longue histoire de transformation de
rupture vous évoquez ce point tout à
l'heure avec la libéralisation du
secteur du transport
on est passé de 20 mille taxi à 45000
taxi plus vtc et là encore bravo aux
taxis ils ont ils ont fait leur
révolution culturelle
on tire notre épingle du jeu grâce à la
premiumisation ils se sont appliqués à
est toujours et les véhicules plus
qualitatif le le costume et la cravate
oui mais alors on va en parler de ça
parce que ça c'est ça s'est passé dans
les cinq ou dix dernières années la cinq
dernières années ça a quand même été une
révolution très fort mais les les des
taxis de la marne c'était des gsm
c'était des gsm absolument ils auront
permis de convoyer nos valeureux soldats
pour mettre fin à l' le feu ralentir
l'offensive allemande est sur les bords
ciel pas d'autre moyen de transport
c'est ce qui a permis d'aller très vite
et 2 et 2 et de convoyer nos soldats
très rapidement il arrêter l'offensive
allemand alors l'histoire de dit que le
ministère de la défense avait payé les
courses aller retour c'est des
indépendants il est normal de payer leur
travail ils ont acheté la voiture il
ils vivent de ça dont les chauffeurs de
taxi donc il est normal qu'on paye les
courses quel que soit le moment mais en
tant il sait camus qui sont montés au
front
donc c'est comme le fonds sanitaire
bravo comme cette mobilisation il ya un
vrai un vrai sens de l'intérêt général
alors il se trouve que yahia combien 5 6
ans votre profession était une
profession qui évolué
euh doucement un tranquillement sur une
sorte de monopole
vous aviez un monopole inquiéter
octroyés par les pouvoirs publics un le
monopole de la plaque le monopole de la
course et sur ceux est arrivée la
concurrente concurrence effrénée
concurrence libre des vtc way rupture à
la chance lorsque ça alors là qu'est ce
qui se passe où vous vous réveillez le
matin en disant ça y est on est foutu
non il ya le mode le module ce monopole
mois pour moi vous ne voulez mais pas
pour vous poser les modes de transports
urbains pour que la voie publique qui
est un bien commun qui doit être partagé
et soit organisé il faut qu'ils soient
organisés et donc d'ailleurs la licence
de taxi a de l'avenir de l'avenir parce
qu'on peut pas à l'infini augmenter le
nombre de véhicules dans paris et
d'ailleurs la loi d'orientation sur les
mobilités réguler même le nombre de
trottinettes et tant mieux parce que
chaque usage pour chaque besoin de
chaque client doit être organisé la
chaussée doit être organisé c'est un
gros gros choc d'offre
on est passé de on a doublé 20000 à 45
mille véhicules
oui oui avec avec des grèves un parce
que les vous voulez chauffeur de taxi
n'accepte pas ça n'accepte pas l'arrivée
de ces jeunes loups la noms légendaires
au vase non non non le chauffeur taxi se
sont adaptés les chauffeurs de taxi moi
je les ai réunis trois fois au zénith
nous aimions réinventer ils se sont
réinventés ils ont fait leur
transformation la révolution culturelle
c'était pas c'était pas gagné face à des
acteurs aux moyens infinis qui peuvent
perdre des milliards avec en permanence
des actionnaires est ce que vous
racontez là qu'est ce que vous êtes en
train de dire ils perdent des milliards
l'échoppé rugby
c'est pas ce qui m'intéresse c'est mais
chauffeur taxi moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est combien il gagne et ce que je vois
c'est qu'en se transforme en oui ils ont
gagné le pari cette révolution
culturelle l'ont fait c'est l'excellence
sanitaires et maintenant il ya
transition énergétique
quand je vois que les chauffeurs de taxi
à 80 % prennent dévolu green vrai qu'on
a déjà la première flotte en europe
on a quatre mille plus de 4000 véhicules
hybrides ont lancé les véhicules les
greens cab
j'ai été lancé en 2007 le prix de la
course est légèrement un supérieur à le
prix d'une course facturés par un über
ça c'est votre point de vue passez votre
nom et je le sais et c'est votre point
de vue quand il ya une averse
ouais quand il se met à pleuvoir le taxi
c'est des tarifs réglementés donc ça
veut dire qu'on peut pas doubler ou
tripler le prix de la course ça veut
dire qu'il ya eu hier ce ya une
variation des tarifs en fonction des
intempéries ou de l'heure à laquelle on
le prend dans les plateformes über je
suis la concurrence peut-être on ne sait
pas on ne sait pas aller les algorithmes
sont de tout faire de son comme la
formule du coca cola algorithmes sont
d'une clarté absolue donc en tout cas le
tarif réglementé du taxi vous vous
garantit l'absence de surprise
d'ailleurs on a sorti une nouvelle
application g7 où on présente nos huit
services et la fourchette de prix
puisque il est normal les clients ils
veulent avoir une petite idée combien ça
va me coûter exactement il ya un tarif
réglementé il ya un compteur mais
néanmoins on veut savoir combien va me
coûter la course c'est vrai que notre
nouvelle application on vient de sortir
ll à affiner encore les fourchettes les
fourchettes de prix encore une fois
toujours cette idée que aucun doit faire
une bonne affaire sur l'eau d'autres sur
le dos de l'autre ni le client parce que
le chauffeur taxi gagne mal sa vie ni
chauffeur taxi black qui facture soit
aux clients et d'ailleurs au dessus les
tarifs pour les aéroports les forfaits
aéroports sont un succès est là la
profession de taxi
vous parliez tout à l'heure de la
nécessaire modernisation
ils ont adopté les nouveaux codes la
concurrence cantal et loyal on n'a pas
peur alors on va s'arrêter trois minutes
et parce que il faut faire un peu de
publicité ne serait ce que pour les
programmes internes de la chaîne et on
se retrouve dans quelques instants
justement pour pour parler des mutations
à venir
[Musique]
retour sur le plateau de la grande
interview avec nicolas roussel le
président de la csn a beaucoup parlé de
la la contrainte que la pandémie a fait
subir sur la l'ensemble de cette
profession la façon dont vous avez réagi
et puis les mutations auxquelles vous
avez été confrontés notamment avec
l'arrivée sur les marchés des des
grandes plateformes de de vtc est ce que
la situation à paris aujourd'hui vous
paraît à peu près stabilisée
sur le secteur
le secteur il est libéralisée donc il
est libéralisé l'érable à dire eh oui
donc ça veut dire que le nombre de
véhicules à quatre roues pour
transporter les parisiens il peut en
permanence évolué c'est une régulation
par les faillites ce n'est pas une
régulation par le par le nombre donc qui
peut en permanence évolué avec avec des
effets négatifs quant à la pollution
quant aux embouteillages mais ça c'est
un autre est un autre point mais le
secteur il est en évolution permanente
la transformation elle est en évolution
permanente
la hache de guerre entre les vtc et les
taxis l etat elle est enterrée là
aujourd'hui
non c'est le combat il est chaque ours
vrai à chaque course on en est on avec
ces nouveaux vengeurs sur le green avec
ce ce pari à apaiser cette cette
nécessité pour nous les taxis d'être un
acteur de la baisse de la pollution en
ville on en discute et on a parlé tout à
l'heure 1 47 % de notre flotte et déjà
green l'horizon suivant c'est les
véhicules électriques avec nous tous les
véhicules électriques qui sortent partir
du moment où c'est pas des suv donc des
véhicules lourds peu adaptés aux centres
urbains
on essaye tous les véhicules électriques
on se bat j'ai écrit à aura maire
d'arrondissement omise de l'économie
pour qui l'équipe au plus vite en
recharge rapide les principales stations
de taxis dans paris on a en permanence
cette transformation nos concitoyens ils
attendent une amélioration de la qualité
de l'air et ça tombe bien les taxis
c'est à la fois des victimes de la
pollution il passe 11 heures par jour
dans leur véhicule donc au niveau de ddd
d'époque des gaz polluer mbour la
solution aux problèmes de pollution et
maintenant qu'on a du green à 47%
on est connecté c'est des véhicules
partagés c'est vraiment là
l'avenir de la ville en coexistant avec
les mobilités douces avec la marche et
quand même aujourd'hui le le premier
mode de transport en ile de france on
cohabite avec les trottinettes avec les
vélos et tout ça forme un écosystème qui
a vocation à baisser la voiture
individuelle et la l'ensemble des
décideurs sur cette même ligne
sous réserve qu'on est nous les taxis
les infrastructures de recharge au plus
vite mais cela tombe bien on a pu le
voir à l'occasion de des élections
régionales
l'ensemble des partis se sont vraiment
beaucoup impliqué dans le développement
d'infrastructures très rapide pour
recharger oui mais ça ça participe de
votre de votre existence que de ce que
de vous battre sur les nouvelles
mobilités
est ce que est ce que vous avez le
sentiment que vous que vos chauffeurs
jouent au même rythme que vous dans
cette affaire est-ce que vous voilà vous
avez par exemple une grille de deux
voitures que vous leur imposez ou que
vous leur conseiller d'acheter ou
ou d'investir une couleur une
motorisation
oui on est on est très proches de nos
chauffeurs nous nous on a des
commissions de concertation qui se
tiennent tous les mois et c'est vraiment
des outils un peu de cogestion c'est eux
qui achètent le véhicule
donc quoi de plus naturel qu'on discute
ensemble de ce qu'on met en place de ce
qu'on n'est pas en attente de ce conte
le même pas en placement et c'est vrai
qu'ils sont très il ya une vraie
sensibilité écologique mais pour eux par
contre on teste les véhicules là la
semaine dernière il ya une nouvelle
marc dont je vais pas citer le nom
électrique à 500 km d'autonomie une
alternatif une alternative à une grande
berline californienne on en a commandé
cinq on va les tester on va voir si
c'est un bon outil qu'on peut conseiller
à nos chauffeurs de taxi cette chose une
marque américaine ça
non justement la marque américaine gem
on essaie de trouver une alternative à
la voile et de trouver une alternative à
tesla quoi moi je ne me serais pas plus
juste et le portable et visite quand est
ce que dans un avenir plus ou moins
proche
on sera dans la même situation à paris
qu'on peut l'être à à londres ou à new
york
c'est à dire on est quasiment on n'a
plus de voiture individuelle voiture
individuelle en centre ville disparaît
elle va disparaître
on aura vous savez qu'on a une autre
société qui s'appelle ada qui fait la
location de véhicules connectés on à
2500 véhicules connectés vous arrivez
vous prenez votre voiture qui est garé
pour le pour partir en week-end et vous
instantanément vous pouvez rentrer dans
le véhicule
donc l'avenir c'est ça c'est de se
débarrasser de son véhicule individuel
pour d'ailleurs économiser du pouvoir
d'achat et pour ne payer que quand vous
utilisez votre voiture à quatre roues
c'est vraiment toute stratégie quand on
est sûr g7
on a on a par exemple dans les huit
services qu'on propose on a des sièges
bébé on a des véhicules accessibles pour
les personnes à mobilité réduite
donc est ce qu'on a besoin d'acheter un
véhicule avec des avec des sièges bébé
la réponse est non sur g7 vous trouvez
ça vous pouvait avoir levé grandi en
plus mais enfin de voir que la
vieillesse si c'est vrai c'est vraiment
notre notre mission chez g7 de mobilité
pour tous pour éviter d'avoir à acheter
un véhicule individuel donc la voiture
la voiture connectée va y avoir la
voiture autonome aussi vous préparer sa
la voiture autonome peut-être peut-être
pour nous pour nous
l'humain est fondamental peut-être mais
on sait très bien que les grands patrons
de plateformes
s'ils essaient déjà
prépare donc vous le préparez pour pour
se débarrasser des chauffeurs n'ont pas
forcément moi je veux pas walchhofer
s'éteint c'est un actif dans le c'est un
plus c'est celui qui entretient
parfaitement sa voiture celui qui porte
beau valise qui ouvre la porte
c'est toujours cela chauffait c'est le
premium vous pouvez pas dissocier la
qualité de service du fait qu'il ya un
humain derrière le volant
mettez dedans mentalement la voiture la
voiture autonome et ça peut fonctionner
aujourd'hui si ça permet de de
d'économiser un petit peu de fatigue au
chauffeur avec des fonctions autonome
sur des portions de routes autonome
pourquoi la voiture autonome encore une
fois des camions autonome quand ils sont
en file indienne sur le sur l'autoroute
on sait très bien est formidable mais
mais dans une activité comme la mienne
quand y'a 20 personnes par jour
le bon entretien du véhicule et c'est un
individu qu'il fait c'est le chauffeur
consciencieux c'est précieux
c'est ça le premium le premium c'est
c'est l'humain c'est pas des robots
partout donc alors c'est lié aussi à à
l'écosystème c'est à dire des
infrastructures est ce que vous négociez
avec la mairie de paris sur les
rénovations urbaines sur les changements
de dax et les changements de couloir
circulation parce qu'on a le sentiment
que la part parfois un peu dans tous les
sens
il est en tout cas le combat pour
améliorer la qualité de l'air que ce
soit la mairie de paris que ce soit la
présidente de la région sont des
couteaux des combats tout à fait
respectable auquel nous on s'associe et
comme acteurs de la mobilité en ville et
20 millions de personnes transportées
par angers 7
on est évidemment en discussion
permanente pour réfléchir
il est normal que les décideurs
politiques fassent déteste voir comment
ça se passe c'est des grosses
révolutions qui sont actuellement en
route et heureusement on a des milliers
de morts avec la pollution dans les
grands deux jours ben une zone urbaine
donc bien sûr on discute on réfléchit on
voit et nous on fait notre part du
chemin notre part du chemin
c'est cette ce verdissement des flottes
c'est important les taxis peuvent
accéder dans les zones où la circulation
est limitée mais en contrepartie le taxi
il investit dans un véhicule gris 80% de
renouvellement des véhicules aujourd'hui
des taxis sont des véhicules hybrides ou
électriques
bravo avec une aide publique
avec des aides publiques comment les
particuliers avec des aides publiques
absolument aussi bien étatique des aides
delà de la mairie de la région
l'ensemble de l'écosystème politiques
entrepreneurs travaillent à améliorer la
qualité de l'air cc c'est ce que nous
demande nos concitoyens moi j'ai des
abonnés en a 200 m on est plusieurs
centaines d'abonnés qui ne veulent qu'un
véhicule g7 green
ils veulent 40 d'hybrides qui fait moins
de 60 ou 80 grammes de co2 il ya des
engagements citoyens qui commence à se
développer que c'est le consommateur qui
fait la loi finalement c'est lui qui
vote
absolument absolument et il a besoin
d'eux il a besoin que son air soit pur
et on est tous à son service et votre
objectif c'est de transformer la
totalité de la flotte avec à l'horizon
alors nous on a les horizons assez
courts c'est-à-dire que quand on était
en 2007 que j'ai lancé les véhicules gsm
green
je m'étais engagé à baisser de 50% les
émissions de co2 et ça a été fait ça a
été fait dès grâce à un véhicule d'une
marque japonaise hybride qui a permis de
considérablement baissé les évolutions
de les émanations de co2 là j'avais
annoncé on sera 50 % de la flotte pour
2021 j'énonce j'ai annoncé ça il ya deux
ans on est à 47 % et notre notre
nouvelle frontière ça va être cette
électrification
mais c'est vrai que là
et qui pour rapidement de charge rapide
le chauffeur de taxi il à 11 heures par
jour il peut pas perdre une heure ou
deux pour recharger son véhicule dont
qui s'équipera en électrique sous
réserve que les infrastructures qu'ils
soient mises à leur disposition par la
puissance publique
en tout cas on y travaille et on discute
beaucoup avec avec l'ensemble des
acteurs politiques pour accélérer la
transformation et répondre présent
la mairie la région ils répondent
présents et les grandes applications de
circulation type mappy ou où les autres
vous utilisez laquelle s est alors nommé
laisse et à la liberté du chauffeur ou
c'est un fou s'est imposée par la
centrale non c'est pas imposer on met à
sa disposition
ouais ouais on a on a renouvelé tous les
ordinateurs on équipe les 900 chauffeurs
parisiens sont tous équipés d'un
ordinateur on a renouvelé hier waits et
wade sa peau est ouest dans nos
calculateur on a on utilise google maps
on travaille avec d'autres d'autres
fournisseurs les trafics pour toujours
vous donnez à vos clients
la fourchette de prix qui correspond le
plus à ce qui va être dans la réalité
dans un environnement compliqué vous
avez vu la circulation paris elle est
chez elle et elle est difficile
votre concurrence avec la bicyclette
et pas mon concurrent la bicyclette la
bicyclette c'est un mode de transport
alternatif c'est la mobilité douce vous
avez un taxi électrique
on a déjà quelques dizaines de taxis
mais la mairie de paris fait une
promotion pour la bicyclette
tant mieux mais tant mieux ça correspond
à un usage ça correspond à une saison
aussi un climat bon ça correspond aussi
à la chicane avec assistance électrique
un formidable un formidable ans études
c'est un progrès qu'on peut qu
encourager et lala quoi vit la
coexistence la cohabitation entre des
taxi partagé green et les vélos ça
fonctionne très bien
le client choisit si on ferme les voir
aussi pour que les vélos puissent
circuler et ça peut gêner les taxis
mission difficile pour les pouvoirs
publics d'arbitré en permanence sur le
partage de la chaussée
en tout cas avec les taxis c'est facile
leur nombre et leur nombre est fixé
donc c'est pas à l'infini le nombre de
véhicules d'ailleurs un peu encombré il
a chaussé ya des vies blanc et des
métropoles dans le monde
ils sont des modèles pour vos
d'organisation
chacko la mobilité chaque villa c'est
paris on n'a pas à rougir on a une telle
profusion de mode de transport à la
disposition des parisiens
enfin que franchement on peut on peut on
peut ricola oui moi je pense qu'on peut
faire on peut lire absolument
nicolas rousset merci beaucoup on
retrouve les missions en replay sur la
chaîne bien sûr en replay puis sur tous
les réseaux sociaux et puis sur le site
internet rtl et france pourrait t b
merci à tous merci merci et à très
bientôt
[Musique]